Transcriber: Aya Motaz
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
[ميسلون فاخر هاشم]
يوجد في أغرافنا عند تغسيل الميت،
أنه في المرة الخامسة
يُمسح بمادة الكافور،
وهي مادة تستخرج من لحاء شجرة الكافور،
حتى يطيب هذا الجسد ويذهب إلى عالمه الآخر،
وييطىء تفسخ الجسد حتى يكون صلب البدن.
بعد اندلاع الحرب العراقية الإيرانية،
ولمدة ثماني سنوات،
انتشر الموت وزاد في العراق،
وارتبطت رائحة الكافور عندي بالموت.
وظلّت تحاصرني هذه الرائحة
مثلما الموت حاصرنا في العراق .
وكان هذا الموت يتمشَى معنا في الشوارع،
ويصعد الباصات إلى المدارس ويسمع أغانينا.
لكن عندما غفلنا، حصد أرواح
نصف مليون شاب عراقي،
بما تعنيه الكلمة من يُتم،
وترمُّل وخسارة تنموية.
وازدادت الظروف صعوبة.
وكانت عائلاتنا في تلك الأيام، أيام الحرب،
عندما تتجمع مساءًا
في الشتاء بجانب المدافئ،
تهمس بخوف وخشية عن مخاوفها
من هذه الحرب واستياءها.
لكن مع ذلك،  كانت الناس صامدة.
ظلّت هذه القصص تلاحقنا،
ولم نقدر أن نهرب منها.
نحن نعرف أن الحرب
ليست في قرار وقف اطلاق النار،
بل بتداعياتها حتى بعد وقف اطلاق النار.
وكانت هذه الأمور تزداد سوءًا
بالحرب العراقية الإيرانية.
ولم نصدق أنفسنا أننا خرجنا من الحرب
العراقية الإيرانية بعد كل هذه الخسائر.
وابتلينا بموت جماعي،
ألا وهو حماقة غزو الكويت.
وبعد أن خرج النظام من الكويت،
ساءت الأحوال وتعرض العراق إلى أقسى ظروف،
أقسى حصار في التاريخ لمدة 13 سنة.
حصار لم يتعرض له أي مجتمع في العصر الحديث.
ازدادت الأمور سوءًا،
وتعرض المجتمع إلى التجريف الأخلاقي،
وصارت الناس تكابد من أجل لقمة العيش.
وأول طبقة انهارت هي الطبقة الفقيرة،
التي ازدادت فقرًا،
كما انحسرت الطبقة المتوسطة.
ظلت الأمور تسوء وتسوء. وفجأة،
صارت بغداد متهالكة، والأمور صعبة.
كان من الصعب على الناس
أن تتحمل هذه الظروف الصعبة؛
فاضطر بعض الآباء،
وخصوصًا في الظروف القاسية بالنسبة إليهم،
أن يزوجون بناتهم أي زيجة،
من أجل أي مبلغ، حتى يسدون به رمق العائلات.
وهذا الموقف دفع بهؤلاء النساء في النهاية
إما أن ينتحرن أو يُقتلن.
أو ذلك الأسير الذي يرجع،
بعد أن أفنى عمره من أجل الوطن،
وهو محملٌ بأحلامه،
حتى يرد الجميل،
ليجد هذا الوطن قد تأثر قبله
وليس لديه ما يعطيه.
ويبحث كلاهما عن الآخر،
وحين يتعثر اللقاء،
يكون قد ضاع العمر ولم يجدا بعضهما البعض.
أو تلك السيدة التي تذهب إلى المستشفى
حتى تنجب وليدها الأول،
يلتقيها إرهابي يفجّر نفسه،
تنتهي حياتها وأحلامها على جادّة المستشفى.
كل هذه الصور ظلّت تلاحقني،
ولم أقوَ على الفرار منها.
لكني وجدت سبيلًا للتحرر
من هذه الكوابيس في أن أتحدث عنها.
وأُصرح عن مشاعري وأكافح وأجاهد
بشكل يومي حتى أتخلص منها،
وفعلًا وجدتها مُلهمة بالنسبة لي.
وكتبت روايتي الأولى بعنوان رائحة الكافور
في 2018 التي صدرت في بغداد.
ظلت ذاكرتي مزدحمة ومشحونة بقصص مؤلمة،
وكنت قريبة من قصص اللاجئين العراقيين
الذين يهربون من الوطن،
بسبب حكومات جائرة أو منظومة فاشلة،
تقدّم لهم أبسط الحقوق التي هي:
سلامتهم وكرامة محفوظة.
لكن حتى هذه الفرصة لم يحصلوا عليها،
فاضطروا إلى الهروب، جحيم الهروب.
صعدوا في قوارب تشبه قوارب الإنقاذ،
التي هي قوارب بلاستيكية،
وكانت هذه القوارب في عُرْض بحار هائجة.
أو انحشروا متجمعين فيما يشبه
علب سمك السردين متعفنة،
أو سُلّموا إلى مهربين بلا ضمير.
وكان هؤلاء المهربون يرمونهم في مناطق وعرة،
حتى يتسلّمهم حراس الحدود في تلك البلدان،
ويحاصرونهم بالأسلاك الشائكة حتى يتجمدون
في ذلك الشتاء القاسي في أوروبا.
وتنتهي حياتهم بالموت أو الاعتقال.
ونحن نعرف أن قسوة الغربة وبشاعتها،
ليست أقل من ذُل المواطن ووجعه في وطنة،
هي غربة بين الحالتين.
هي في كل الأحوال وجع وخيبة.
تغّول المجتمع وساءت الأحوال،
وفقدنا الجمال وخسرنا إنسانيتنا.
حتى نحن الهاربون، فقدنا إنسانيتنا.
ونحن المحاصرون في الوطن، فقدنا إنسانيتنا.
وظلت هذه القصص المؤلمة تلاحقنا.
وأنا قدرت التخلص من هذه الحالة،
بأن كتبت روايتي الثانية بعنوان
صلصال امرأتين التي صدرت في بغداد عام 2020؛
التي تتحدث عن هذا الوجع، وجع الهجرة.
ومع ذلك ظلت عندي قصص حزينة،
ومؤلمة تحاصرني ولم أقدر أن أتخطاها.
بعد الاحتلال الأمريكي ساءت الأحوال،
ووصل أمن الوطن إلى نقطة الصفر.
وصل الحد بأفراد العصابات
أن تمسك الناس في الشارع،
وتختطفهم حتى تتاج بأعضائهم البشرية.
ولسوء الحظ، كانت هناك فتاة صغيرة،
على سبيل المثال، قد تعرضت للاختطاف
وعانت الويلات من هذا الاختطاف؛
مرة بالتعذيب اليومي،
ومرة بالاغتصاب وأخيرًا بالرعب.
إلى أن جاءتها فرصة سريالية، مثل الحلم،
تحررها من هذه العصابة،
وتقدر الهروب منهم، ولكن لم تقدر
الهروب لا من كآبتها السوداء
ولا من كلب أسود ظل يحاصرها
ويلاحقها وهو حزنها وخيبتها،
في أن تعرض جسدها للتدنيس،
وكرامتها كانت مدانة.
أيضًا جاءتها فرصة مثل الحلم،
لأن تلتقي بهؤلاء الجناة وجهًا لوجه،
ولكن بمواقع متبادلة.
حتى تتحرر من هذا الإثم الذي دنس جسدها،
كانت قد وجهت له بصقة بوجهه عندما اغتصبها،
حتى تقدر تتحرر من هذا الكابوس
الذي كان يطاردها.
وفعلًا وجهت هذه البصقة وأحست بنفسها
أنها تحررت من هذا الحزن والكلب الأسود.
وهذه هي  تفاصيل روايتي الثالثة
بعنوان الكلب الأسود،
التي صدرت عام 2021 في بغداد.
يشرفني أن أكون اليوم ضيفتكم،
وأن أعبر عن صوت كل شخوص رواياتي،
وعن كل المنهكين والبائسين الذين تشتتوا،
ولم يتبقَ منهم غير الأمل.
وأتمنى، أتمنى من كل قلبي،
أن نعبر جميعًا، نحن وهذا الوطن من النفق.
وألا نحتاج لذل الهروب أو الغربة،
أو أحد يتاجر بأعضائنا البشرية،
أو يفجرنا في الشوارع،
أو يغيبنا بشكل قسري لأسباب غير معروفة.
هذا الوطن العراق،
صمد بأهله رغم كل الخيبات والوجع.
هذا العراق يستحق منّا
أن ننهض به وأن ينهض بنا.
وحتى يستعيد عافيته هذا الوطن،
علينا أن نطور الشعور بأحقيتنا وفخرنا به،
ونعيد تقييم دورنا بهذا المجتمع.
أفعال صغيرة وبسيطة، متكررة بجد ومثابرة،
يمكن أن تُحدث تغييرًا بوجه عالمنا.
وكل واحد فينا معني ومساهم بهذا التغيير.
حتى نستعيد أماكننا التي نحبها بهذا الوطن،
ونستعيد فرحنا بهذا الوطن،
وسوف ننتظر هذا اليوم،
وسوف نجد شفاعةً لهذا التأخير،
بقول المتنبّي:
“بلادي وإن جارت علي عزيزةٌ،
وأهلي وإن ضنّوا علي كرام“.
كونوا أنتم العظماء،
وقودوا مسيرة الخلاص لهذا العراق العظيم.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)